the biggest reason people aren't happy
right now is because they value somebody
else's opinion more than they value
their own while there's a plenty of
wrong and plenty of right in the world
it comes down to one very simple thing
what are you choosing to look for we
lack perspective your conference cut the
boohoo
I lost a client boohoo there's people
dying out there
need motivation watch the top 10 with
belief nation what's up at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded under
the world so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and show in today's lessons
from a man who went from being born in
the Soviet Union moving to the United
States starting multiple little
businesses like lemonade stains to now
becoming one of the greatest
entrepreneurs of our generation he's
Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 5
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one go on the offense the biggest
reason people aren't happy right now is
because they value somebody else's
opinion more than they value their own
that is the number one blanket statement
that I've got for everybody you're your
mother's point of view on you your
wife's point of view on you you're your
boyfriend's point of view your homies
point of view like the reason I'm super
happy is nobody can tell me nothing my
wife mom and daughter could walk into my
room right now tell me I'm a piece of
crap and I would be 100% on things that
is some gangster emotional structure and
that's why I can never use I Know Who I
am
and I just am unfazed so if my mom
daughter and wife could come in and tell
me I'm a piece of crap and I'm cool what
do you think that troll on Instagram
that says I suck does nothing so you
need to figure out the following it is
very likely that either your mom or dad
screwed you up they made you insecure
they didn't love you enough they told
you they you aren't good because they
weren't good and misery loves company
once you face that demon once you cut
out negativity and the people that hold
you down and you surround yourself with
positivity and don't confuse delusion
don't watch my videos and rah rah up and
you don't put any work in nothing good
is gonna happen
you're just gonna watch my videos so
don't get it confused but life is basic
you're either on the optimism team or
you're on the pessimism team your other
you're either on the offense or you're
on the defense the reason people are
unhappy is because let's talk about
money and unhappiness your three best
friends have a BMW and you don't you
think it's that you don't realize that I
loved when all my friends had BMWs and I
had nothing it's just perspective man
what are we doing here
like what are you valuing like what was
everybody's on defense all the
immigration issues in the world nobody's
taking yours any think some immigrants
taking your job you suck
like if you think that right do you
think somebody else is taking your spot
this is the world we live in
Richard you don't rich this world in the
UK market you live in the UK and you're
complaining get the hell out of here so
so that's practical you you have a
family member or a childhood that put
you in a mindset of defense and listen I
know I'm gonna get a lot of hits on
Twitter and Instagram about this
interview now when I spit this because I
know a lot of people haven't heard of me
or to have context I mean let me just
say this the answer to everything is and
what now right like I know people grew
up in alcoholic households I know people
were molested I know people had somebody
steal all their money here's my problem
nobody cares like what are you waiting
for
like like nobody's there is no fair
fairy flying down from the earth and
saying you were born an African American
in America where that's an issue here's
a million dollar it's not happening so
my thing is instead of dwelling and
wishing how it was understand back to
the next practical part of your question
that the Internet is now here and guess
what the Internet's not a 76 year old
white man it's the Internet and that
means everybody's got a shot so go take
yours it's happening on YouTube Facebook
Instagram go figure it out instead of
shooting on it and thinking it sucks and
go get your money happiness and that's
it simple as that I got no time for
people complaining because it's just not
clean anymore 1986
yes 2018 what do you think's going why
do you think me too is happening now the
Internet one it's over
go get yours rule number two fall in
love with the game what do you think the
minimum amount of money you want to make
for your life like like like what would
be the minimum amount of money that you
make every year that allowed you to live
and do that content media site what do
you think
great so you're like what is amazing
about that if that's where you're at
well then at this young of an age and
well that's where you're at and the fact
that you're even here and you know it's
just unbelievable amounts of content in
written audio and visual form on
Instagram snapchat Facebook Twitter and
YouTube and podcast and I will tell you
I would be flabbergasted in three four
five six years unless you suck what you
may but if you don't suck and you have
that little of a financial need right
which is remarkable which is the biggest
thing something here I don't know if
they're here said you made me realize I
didn't need Rolexes and things of that
nature right like the biggest reason so
many of you will fail is your number for
success is far greater than his you
think you need a million which will then
mean that you're gonna do a lot of
things when you don't get a million very
quickly that won't ever get you a
million so if you if you think what I
just said is cool which is bleed for six
years in a row
you'll probably get sponsorship or sales
of product to 40,000 a year to me that's
what I did I knew what I wanted I was
willing to give up my 20s for it gave
him up gave him up you know somebody
said it's difficult not to document
right now I'm like but I but I didn't
write but like what should I build my
business or should I document I'm like
both he's like well I gotta pick one I'm
like build your business like so if
you're if your ambitions are that humble
which they are that's incredible that
excites me because by the way here's the
funny part that's why I was too I just
needed a hundred thousand a year just
that seemed rich to me right like I was
like cool um I'll be okay
like like I'll have a house like you
know it's not you know I just needed to
play much I needed the game and too many
people too many of you in here want the
stuff not the game when you fall in love
with the game everything's different
because you've already won that's real
it sounds cliche but it's real rule
number three look for positivity you
find what you're looking for I've been
giving a lot of thought
just watching what I'm seeing out there
in the social digital ecosystem and very
honestly just real life and I'm watching
so many people over the last two to
three years look for negativity look for
something that's wrong
find where people disagree with them
fight look for what was me downside to
half glass empty and then I go to a
twitter search or look around the world
and I find ridiculously beautiful things
every day every day thousands of kind
acts randomly by people all people that
I have conversations with who see the
opportunities whether it's in business
like voice and AR or crypto or whatever
it may be just this amazingly
interesting thing that I feel the
majority of you are looking for the
wrong
while there's plenty of wrong and plenty
of right in the world it comes down to
one very simple thing what are you
choosing to look for because I promise
you if you right now and I'm making this
video for one reason 24 hours of trying
to find the good somebody saves a kid
somebody opens the door somebody does a
nice thing for you bit somebody system
thank you 24 hours of looking for
positivity could change your life
honestly making this for one person one
one person watches this video chooses to
do 24 hours of looking for good instead
of looking for bad and their game
changes d-roc heard somebody at a
convenience store saying mom you're
always so negative you're always so
negative I am blown away by the fact
that life gets real simple if you break
down into this are you looking for the
negative this sucks this government
sucks this person sucks this is or
you're looking for the positive she's
nice that's remarkable I've got this
opportunity you choose what you're
looking for because what you look for
you find that's how life works rule
number four make no excuses I know you
helped a lot of people start especially
younger people but how does a person
with four kids
yes him right now doesn't like his job
yeah but just can't quit and sell stuff
yeah and find stuff in a junkyard so if
you're listening and you're over 42
let's just use my age there's something
interesting you said something that I
helped a lot of people that are younger
it only has to do with one thing they
actually believe in the technology we
live in right this room is filled with
guys right now who've taken advantage of
YouTube or Instagram or just the
Facebook's of the world and the only
thing I need to do to break through
somebody who's 47 in the suburbs of
London who has a mortgage debt and three
children is for them to understand that
unlike when he or she and I grew up and
there was no internet the thought of
like having a happy life was separate
than taking care of what you were
supposed to take care of the fact that
everybody can come home tonight at 6 7 8
9 p.m. and then take out their phone or
their iPad or whatever and get to work
for 3 more hours and go to sleep at
midnight get their good six or seven
hours of sleep I'm not talking about
don't sleep a lot of people get me
confused my big thing is if you're not
happy if you're happy and you make
37,000 pounds a year Mazel Tov do you
but if you are not happy if you hate
your job right you can do something
about it instead of blaming brexit or
blaming Trump or blaming your mom like
do something about it and my point is
it's the Internet right getting today
that sounds awesome
yeah I like it I like it I like it I'll
tell you why because I even I can tell
by your demeanor that you're gonna be
okay the fact that you realize that that
negative moment has positive impact the
question is why did it happen and that's
why you have to be honest with yourself
I don't know you know but that's you
know I'm pumped that you can have the I
mean you're more positive and half the
people here and it sounds like you're
having a terrible day
super-race that's why I wanted to ask
you how do you keep the positivity the
calmness when everything because
basically when things happen I go the
other way so tonight I just was
reminding myself every time I and every
time you came and next person came I'm
just reminding my little e in my own
head saying you don't mean I said to one
of you I said they said how do you stay
humble
when Melin like because I know if I die
tomorrow I'll have a good day on social
media like most comments ever on my
latest post on Instagram everybody to be
like oh that was the last one weird and
and I know that all of you will be on
with your life a week later you have to
balance your ego with humility in the
same way when I'm having my worst day I
realize I'm the best I'm gonna be the
best that ever does this and so the way
I handle things is when something's
going one way I use all my emotional
strength to push the other way what are
you gonna cry for rest your life cuz the
conference comes up like I just like to
me it's just like look what the guys if
you're in this room right now let me
just remind you that there are seven
point seven billion people literally
right now as we stand here there are
women being shipped to be strippers in
parts of our world right now as we stand
here there are women who are basically
caged mentally usually and are being
shipped to dance on a pole in Manhattan
and in London like do you understand
what's good there's there's genocide
going on right now like what do you
think's going on like we lack
perspective your conference got that
boohoo
I lost a client boohoo there's people
dying out there like like so when
Americans or Europeans talk to me about
race or gender I'm sad it's the real
life but I remind them because it's a
positive thing cool but let me tell you
about the person that's ranked seven
billion in the world they have it bad
and so I just I struggle like I want to
run like I listen I'm a leader and I
think about
things like animals like I don't know
like if you're the best elephant
we are still better than you like you
know like without really listen you know
I got hot on this about a year ago the
400 trillion to one it's impossible to
be a human being you won I don't know
how to get upset after that I keep some
perspective right
like you're gonna learn from this you've
got I promise you it's failing because
of you and and when you start owning
your SH and not blaming other people and
I think this is the kick I've been on
lately on Instagram right like blame
yourself
you know why I'm always happy I believe
myself when you blame yourself for real
you're gonna always be happy because you
don't feel like somebody else controls
you rule number six finds your why my
big ambition is to be an all time
entrepreneur by both my success in my
career but what has become more evident
to people I think recently is also by
influencing as many people as possible
in a positive way so that they get
theirs and that means the person that
goes from the job that they're not
excited about to making eighty four you
know thousand sterling a year being
happy talking about their proper
football team on Instagram and YouTube
to the young gal right now in Sweden
who's gonna start a 500 million dollar
you know media company so I think to be
the great entrepreneur of this
generation there's clearly the bezos's
and and the Elon Musk's and the sucks I
don't think I'm gonna be able to create
that kind of wealth
I just want to create obnoxious amount
of wealth
but you know a billion dollars in a
billion people I think puts you above
everybody else and and I think that is
where my behavior is right now like why
am i doing this podcast rule number
seven my personal favorite live with no
regrets but veinous booze new media the
book
yes she's podcast yes you do a lot yeah
man look here's what I think I think we
get one at-bat um the number one thing
that scares me in life is regret I
really really really don't want to be on
my deathbed whether that's tomorrow or
when I'm 97 and think I should have done
that I should like that's that spooks me
right like hard work people judging me
leaving you know trolling me on social
media like all the stuff that normal
people worry about I don't worry about I
worry about regret and so I'm trying to
squeeze the everything out of my life
and so yeah I do a lot rule number eight
hustle under price attention value my
religion my religion to many of you in
here have ego around your time when it's
the only thing you got so the reason I
always know is cuz I work because I work
I work I try things I test IDM you back
I sweet I do I've work so when you're in
you taste it and when you've done it for
20 years
you see patterns Facebook's still
underpriced
you just can't target 22 to 25 year old
african-american fans of football
because other people are doing that too
now it's just like Google early on you
could just target soccer one-word five
cents a click I did it
wine wine wine but then I had to put at
the end of the game now I got to put
2013 you know Heller cellars Zinfandel
like long tail real estate if you're
right about London
look it's my favorites do you know what
you understand that somebody once bought
this building for a doll
somebody bought the land we're on for a
dollar once that happened it's a long
time ago how do you know you're a
practitioner the reason I do is to how I
learned you got to put up all of you
were like well I can't do podcasting and
Facebook and Twitter oh but I can't I
can blog but I can't why if you want it
so bad my thing is why if you want it so
bad why can't if you want to have a
media company around Caribbean food
culture
why can't you I want to you know what I
want to see I want to see all your
minutes I want to see all your minutes I
want to give you a d-roc for today I
want to watch you from the moment you
wake up to the moment you go to sleep
let me promise you something you're
gonna get exposed so so that's why
dailyvee happened because you guys like
a lot of you didn't know me before daily
be how many people knew me before
dailyvee well not bad right you got you
got to really know me post dailyvee you
heard hard work and hustle before you
were confused and I've been doing that
every day for 20 years
rule number 9 maximize your strengths
when I wasn't born six foot seven and
can run like a cheetah I couldn't wish I
was something or I can realize I am
something and try to maximise on that
it's a game of poker you get a hand
nobody's gonna cry for you about your
hand nobody's gonna say oh it's terrible
that you're not fast or tall or gorgeous
of telly or Orkin sing it is what it is
and now the old
that can happen is you can figure out
how to navigate it the second you stop
dwelling and a second you stop start
doing everything changes they don't give
up the second you understand that and
just start trying to make happen with
that energy
you win and rule number 10 the last home
before some very special bonus clips get
Authority I want to be and I want to
stay in there somewhere and find me but
every time I mentioned that lets go you
know we want to do to like I might tell
people go there incident response it is
you know hiding to do that you got
married my parents are born as if I was
eight of them seven eight I'm not
married I can and I can answer your
question right away we're gonna build an
amazing yeah we're gonna build an
amazing case study together I'm gonna
give you I'm gonna give you three names
and then you're gonna cruise into the
sunset of success which is let's figure
out the three most successful coaches in
the history of sport that everybody
knows up that didn't play that sport
Bill Belichick even though I hate him
with all my guts did not play football
he grew up in the football game
right his dad and what it was a coach
what have you but Bill Belichick did not
play football and he will probably
unfortunately go down as the greatest or
if not one of the greatest head coaches
of all time you don't have to be listen
I think you have to be people have to be
thoughtful
I hate twenty two-year-old life coaches
that haven't lived life but if they if
they speak about here's my life
experiences and and why you can
eliminate though very quickly the art
when somebody says to you but how are
you you can't do let me first of all a
couple other questions are your friends
and your circle telling you you can't do
that or are customers that you're trying
to do that with telling you that they
don't want to go with you because you're
not married no this is more
acquaintances are people you know that I
run into yeah so listen that's it was
Saint listen that's a mistake
like you can't listen to acquaintances
or opinions don't matter okay you chill
with some somehow you do it every how do
you have I'm sorry no go ahead I'm sorry
I'm getting excited
you should talk up basically like I
wanna because I follow you and I was
following it for a couple years now and
I do agree what you have to say about
education I do think people are gonna
start moving from you know going to
school is the favorite kid to school to
find you I've got your answer
I've got your answer and a lot of people
get up you don't of course I know I know
exactly where you going so if you're not
gonna get the PhD there's only a few
ways to justify and gives confidence to
the end market what what why they would
jump with you it's crazy to me that so
many people I was watching 60 minutes
last night in the background as I was
working and the way that Oprah was
justifying the person was he has a PhD
in this and a master's in that the even
60 minutes use those pieces of paper to
create a far authority in our society
pieces of paper from businesses and
that's what colleges are has been the
authority the only other people that get
Authority are the people that have gone
out and done it and have people
co-signing them right makes sense so the
way your and this is why I love working
for free when you don't have a piece of
paper right one of the reasons I love
working for free is working for free for
somebody who is that person in society
whether they got a piece of paper or
they're Puff Daddy and they just did it
becomes the equity that you trade under
once you become great at something right
and and Andy who's sitting here right
now have every single famous person I
see gives him a lot of street cred right
away not because he got a degree for
personal branding and marketing for
Virginia Tech with the green you get the
science not because of his [ __ ]
political science degree from Virginia
Tech but because he went and worked
underneath me and I went out and did it
and I always give him love and good
vibes the end it's not babban his degree
from the USC School of film or NYU
I jumped out you know say so what you
need to do it what you need to do is one
of two moves if you're not gonna go get
a PhD and have everybody comfortable
with it you wouldn't need to go work for
somebody that is the authority and ask
all thousands of people that are
authorities and work for them or okay
you need to give your services for free
to five couples crush it for them and
use their word-of-mouth and endorsements
and as your leverage point the end
now I've got two very special garyvee
bonus clips around how to define your
ambitions and how to get things done but
before that I want to throw it to you
what did you learn from this video that
you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or your business
what's the biggest lesson that you took
from this write it down leave in the
comments below when you write something
down it's much more likely to stick so
let this be the seed that allows you to
explode and do great things leave it in
the comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
once you got the money yeah and you get
your first paycheck you're like you know
what I've got some money in the bank now
where do you go so but then money I
think the reason you feel right now is
about a year ago I got into the whole
mindset of like oh crap there's a lot of
people watching me who have zero so I
started talking about the flip challenge
and go to Craigslist but in general most
of my career was talking more about
people that had a little something
that's a very easy place for me I think
the answer to you or anybody who's
listening is what do you want to happen
in life I want to buy the New York Jets
American football team I've got to be on
the offense you know but if you have a
little bit of money and you don't want
to work super hard for the rest of your
life and you don't have ambition for all
time legacy well then you should put
your money into Facebook and Amazon
stock and watch it grow over the next 20
years and buy yourself a nice little
college cottage in the country when
you're done the answer to your question
is completely 100% predicated on your
ambition
what is the ambition that you have if
you want to buy a Premier League team
you better go on the offense and pour
every one of those dollars back into
hyper upside if you want to just chill
and then smoke weed and Ibiza well then
you don't have to why do you hate
Friday's so much because I hate people
that live their lives for the weekend
I'm blown away by people celebrating the
end of the week
like the weekend is your escape from
your reality it breaks my heart my
friends like live for Friday night like
they know they get the wait like Monday
morning is the worst to live your life
where you love Friday night Saturday and
Sunday and despise Monday through
Thursday or Friday morning is
devastating to me because you're wasting
too much of your life but 50% of your
entire life is predicated on what you do
and we're like it's just a huge
percentage of one's life and I'm trying
to put pressure on the conversation to
say if you love Friday that much then
you need to really look at Monday
through Thursday and see if you can do
something about it Sunday night I'm like
chomping I'm like a fighter before a
fight like in the dressing room like I
can't like I try to go to sleep early on
something because I can't wait for
Monday cuz I get to put my jersey this
is not your grandpappy's life we have
the Internet you can make happen you can
build businesses or side hustles take
less money and like live a little more
humbly to set up your next 50 years so
many of you are so hungry for short term
short term gains like maximizing the job
that paid you $3,000 more but it's not
as fun but you want that $3,000 for what
for what for a new iPhone
either live life one time I'm talking
about if you genuinely dislike what you
do so much that you Bank for Friday
listen I live years of this and
definitely at least nine I just don't
understand why people relegate into
losing mentality just thinking they can
you can't because you want to be on the
bowling team or softball and play video
games that's why you can there's plenty
of time get you done raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people your passion and not one
drop of most self-worth depends on your
it's supposed to mean I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details